on va analyser tout cela avec francis
généreux économiste principal chez
desjardins bonsoir bonsoir
d'abord est-ce qu'on est surpris est ce
que vous êtes surpris de la rapidité de
la reprise de l'emploi aux états unis
pat en juin le mois de mai avait été
beaucoup plus étonnant quand les choses
sont sorties alors qu'on s'attendait
encore à dubaï 6 mai ou juin
oui c'est un gros chiffre 4 millions 800
mille le précédent record évidemment
cette année sinon avant sauf pour tomber
en 1983 mais mais on savait que ça
pourrait être un gros chiffre est il
faut falloir s'habituer à voir des gros
chiffres positifs après avoir des gros
chiffres négatifs qu'on a eu en mars
alors voici un graphique que vous avez
préparé pour nous sur le nombre
d'emplois dans l'économie depuis 2008 on
voit la chute de 2009 et 2009 qui a
l'air bien modeste à côté de ce qu'on a
connu 10 12 ans plus tard la forte chute
à 2020 d'un coup ça remonte mais encore
beaucoup de terrain reprendre oui tout à
fait on a gagné par un tiers des emplois
perdus en mars et avril sont conscients
qu'on prend si on additionne les gains
de mai et juin
donc oui c'est des chiffres aussi qu'on
eut récemment mais le manque à gagner
est encore énorme et la marche reste
entre autres pour les prochains mois
autre graphique qui nous montre les
chômeurs permanent le taux de chômage
permanent et le taux de chômage
temporaire les chômeurs temporaires
expliquez nous donc il faut qu'on compte
qu'une grosse partie des pertes d'emploi
qu'on a connu en mars et avril prenait
beaucoup d emplois des pertes d'emplois
temporaires
donc c'est ont dit anne entre
l'employeur et l'employé n'a évidemment
je peux pas fonctionner mais dès que ça
la machine capable dès qu'on peut ouvrir
on embauche et ses voix c'est ça aussi
qu'on voit présentement légué d'emploi
qu'on a vu au cours des derniers mois
c'est c'est vraiment de ce côté là
qu'est ce qui est un peu plus inquiétant
c'est que les mises à pied mais
permanente alors que le poste lui est
abolie et on ne donne pas de date de
retour
cette hausse a augmenté de 588 588
milles au courant du mois de juin
c'était déjà en hausse les mois d'avant
donc ça ressemble ce côté l'agaçante
plus à une version un peu plus classique
d'avoir une remontée de ce côté là
tandis que les chiffres d'emploi conte
avec les grandes variations ne
proviennent plus des emplois temporaires
et c'est à peu près quoi 3 millions dans
deux personnes qui ont été licenciées
l'a vraiment pertes d'emplois définitive
on est rendu à deux millions de 183 me
au niveau
en juin deux des gens qui ont dans
l'ensemble perdu leur emploi au courant
des derniers mois et qu'ils n'ont pas de
date de retour
est ce que les chiffres de l'emploi
réflète ce qui se passe réellement dans
l'économie américaine
oui dans un certain sens et qu'on voit
on a vu des grosses baisses autant
d'emplois que de l'activité économique
en général en mars avril avec le groupe
déconfinement avec les l'art est
vraiment tout côtoie depuis on voit des
gros chiffres mais positif on a vu des
ventes au détail qui ont augmenté les
ventes d'autos en mai augmenté de 40 %
les ventes au détail d'avril 13%
donc on voit encore des gros chiffres
souvent des records lorsqu'on regarde
les variations mensuelles
mais tous ces éléments là autant
l'emploi que les autres statistiques
nous montre surtout que oui ça remonte
mais on est encore loin des niveaux
qu'on avait avant la pandémie lynwood
mode janvier la remontée importante des
99 et c'est très clair est ce que vous
considérez que c'est inquiétant
en ce moment de voir cela sur le plan
économique depuis le début ça a toujours
été le principal risque qu'on fait des
scénarios économiques pour les états
unis pour ailleurs dans le monde si
c'est de voir si vraiment ça de risques
l'incertitude est toujours venue de
l'évolution de la pandémie et qu'est ce
qu'on veut aux états unis mais
évidemment c'est un risque négatif qui
commença de monter plus qu'on l'espérait
donc il faut voir que peut-être le
pourront maintenant craint que les gros
chiffres de croissance qu'on a
présentement qui devrait se manifester
dans le pib du 3ème du quatrième
trimestre mais aussi il faut un peu
ralentir encore plus la machine cie va
voir d'autres mesures sanitaires et de
confier
main sa préférence autres que la copie
de votre beaucoup plus lent qu'est-ce
qu'on respecte et jusqu'à quel point
vous pensez que les autorités vont
refermer l'économie là où il ya des
signaux très clairs de deuxième vague de
kobe 19 aux états unis ça semble sommes
encore griffe qu'acteur il était déjà
très facteurs affectant certains états
dont beaucoup fait la californie ni à
l'illinois
mais dans le sud notamment où est-ce
qu'on voit les cas présentement ou en
floride d'ailleurs en caroline du sud
mais on est déjà eu quelques acteurs
mais qu'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on veut
plus y aller peut-être autant que des
fermetures at large de grands pans de
l'économie
mais puisque des mesures sanitaires et
exerce annoncée aujourd'hui va falloir
maintenant porter un masque
oui lesquelles il faut venir d'autres et
a aussi annoncé comme les fermetures de
bach dont peut-être certains points plus
précis où les gens se regrouper avec des
situations des listes qu'on sent que ça
va fermer
mais on pense pas que ça va complètement
contrecarrer la reprise et la relance
est ralentie au canada dans les chiffres
vendredi prochain dans une semaine on
s'attend à quoi pendant la même chose en
toutes proportions gardées qu aux
etats-unis dont certains cas une
création de 750 mille emplois quand même
énorme pour les chiffres canadiens pour
le mois de juin mais on avait déjà perdu
à peu près 3 millions d'emplois en mars
et avril avec les gains de 2 300 milles
qu'on avait connu au mois d'avril ça
fait comme aux états unis
on va gagner parce que le tiers des
emplois d'accord c'est ce qu'on va voir
franchi ce généreux merci merci beaucoup